Hi, my name is Joel.
嗨，我叫乔尔。
I'm from New York City and I just wanted to call to make the case that the saluting joke is actually my joke, not Alex joke.
我来自纽约市，我只是想打电话证明这个敬礼笑话实际上是我的笑话，而不是亚历克斯的笑话。
Now, my defense for that is twofold.
现在，我对此的辩护是双重的。
Personally, Alec and I have been best friends since we were five and when asked recently, he couldn't quite remember whose joke it was while I definitely remember that it was my joke.
就我个人而言，亚历克和我从五岁开始就是最好的朋友，最近被问到时，他不太记得这是谁的笑话，而我肯定记得这是我的笑话。
Secondly, ever since I've known him, Alex's record of being wrong about things has been unparalleled.
其次，自从我认识他以来，亚历克斯在事情上犯错的记录是无与伦比的。
And I think those two things taken together definitively make the case.
我认为将这两件事放在一起就可以明确地说明这一点。
Either way, this was a joke that Alec and I used to make to each other all the time.
不管怎样，这都是我和亚历克经常开的玩笑。
And Craig, our friend, dutifully asked if he could use it on the show.
我们的朋友克雷格尽职尽责地询问他是否可以在节目中使用它。
And I appreciate that he did because I think that this will be my lasting legacy and it will be how my children remember me when I'm gone.
我很感激他这样做，因为我认为这将是我永久的遗产，也是我去世后我的孩子们记住我的方式。
So thanks for putting it on the show.
谢谢你把它放在节目中。
Bye.
再见。
Oh, we'll be soon in New York City when I see you.
哦，当我见到你时我们很快就会到纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything in York City.
请允许我告诉你约克市的一切。
Welcome to how we made your mother.
欢迎来到我们如何塑造你的母亲。
I'm Josh.
我是乔什。
We're out here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我们和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯一起来这里。
Say Craig.
说克雷格。
Josh, tell us what we just heard from Alec.
乔什，告诉我们刚刚从亚历克那里听到了什么。
That was your childhood best friend Joel.
那是你儿时最好的朋友乔尔。
That is, that was Joel, my friend since, since we were four, five, six years old.
也就是说，那是乔尔，从我们四、五、六岁时起我的朋友。
I went to elementary school, middle school, high school, and college together.
我一起上小学、初中、高中、大学。
High school was where he learned the saluting joke for me.
高中时他为我学会了敬礼笑话。
Alec, I got to say, it is so generous of you to have acquired that recording and to have played it rather than just flushing it down the toilet.
亚历克，我不得不说，你真是太慷慨了，能得到那段录音并播放它，而不是直接把它冲进马桶。
You're giving equal time to the other point of view.
你给了其他观点同样的时间。
You guys, so just to give a backstory, we had dinner with Joel a few months ago, Alec and I.
你们，简单介绍一下背景故事，几个月前我们和乔尔、亚历克和我共进晚餐。
And this got pretty heated at the dinner because Joel was not happy.
晚餐时，事情变得非常激烈，因为乔尔不高兴。
He was like, he's so convinced it's his joke and you have been so convinced for so long it's your joke.
他就像是，他非常确信这是他的笑话，而你这么久以来一直坚信这是你的笑话。
And I of course borrowed this joke.
我当然借用了这个笑话。
I did ask permission for this one and I put it into this episode.
我确实征求了许可，并将其放入这一集。
I think I did.
我想我做到了。
Didn't I?
我没有吗？
Goddamn it.
该死的。
Okay.
好的。
We'll get to put a pen in that.
我们会在里面放一支笔。
Put a pen in that.
放一支笔进去。
You are, you're a big man.
你是，你是个大人物。
It's big of you to put this in because I am convinced that you're convinced it's your joke.
你把这个放进去真是太伟大了，因为我确信你确信这是你的笑话。
I'm a hundred percent sure.
我百分百确定。
I'm a hundred percent sure it's not a bit.
我百分百确定不是一点点。
You really think it's your joke?
你真以为这是你的玩笑吗？
I definitely think it's my joke.
我绝对认为这是我的笑话。
And I'm just a few words of defense and then I'm gonna go away.
我只是辩护几句然后就走开。
First is it's just the amount of childish and annoying that sounds like it would come from me.
首先，这听起来像是来自我的幼稚和烦人。
That feels like that's my over.
感觉这就是我的结束了。
That was your territory in the friendship.
那是你在友谊中的领地。
It was.
是的。
It's your brand?
是你的品牌吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's still your brand, by the way.
顺便说一句，它仍然是你的品牌。
It's kind of still your brand.
这仍然是你的品牌。
I think we all know actually the Joel when he believes in something, the vociferousness, which he fights for, is strong.
我想我们实际上都知道乔尔，当他相信某件事时，他为之奋斗的呼声是强烈的。
It doesn't mean he's more right.
这并不意味着他更正确。
He just, he leans in, right?
他只是，他靠过来，对吧？
He will agree with that.
他会同意这一点。
I will agree with that.
我同意这一点。
I will say, but how long do you think you were when you came up?
我会说，但是你认为你上来的时候有多久了？
What age were you both when this joke magically was given to you by the gods?
当诸神神奇地给你们讲这个笑话时，你们俩多大了？
That's the best way we came up with that.
这是我们想出的最好方法。
I came up with this in late high school, I want to say, pretty late high school.
我在高中后期想出了这个，我想说，相当晚的高中。
And then I want to also, to the court, if it pleased the court, Joel did make two mistakes in his little message, which I think just eliminates his entire argument.
然后我还想对法庭说，如果法庭高兴的话，乔尔在他的小信息中确实犯了两个错误，我认为这只是消除了他的整个论点。
One is that he said that he skipped over Craig the part where you were a huge part of this.
一是他说他跳过了克雷格，而你在其中扮演了重要角色。
He just went from he and I were using it to and then Craig's permission, which I think was rude because you were very much a part of the saluting culture.
他只是从他和我正在使用它到然后是克雷格的许可，我认为这是粗鲁的，因为你是致敬文化的一部分。
He's a dog with a bone, he's making his case, but we all went to college together to Western University for four years and we did this joke, we came up with variations and it became part of our shared vernacular.
他是一只有骨头的狗，他正在陈述自己的观点，但我们一起在西部大学上大学四年，我们开了这个玩笑，我们想出了一些变体，它成为我们共同的白话的一部分。
I actually think I came up with that, I think it was my joke, I think I invented it in college.
我实际上认为这是我想出来的，我认为这是我的笑话，我认为我在大学时发明了它。
It's fun.
很有趣。
And then the other thing was you did not ask permission for this.
另一件事是你没有为此征求许可。
Oh fuck.
哦操。
And which is fine, I don't mind that, I just like that it showed that Joel is wrong about Yet another thing I believe what happened like days before I want to be angel on that one though I hate to tell you why I think Joe's right about that that didn't happen You just told me that it was coming up and I was thrilled Okay, so I told I gave you a heads up like hey, there's something you're gonna like in this episode Okay, so I see that's what I mean.
这很好，我不介意，我只是喜欢它表明乔尔错了还有一件事我相信几天前发生的事情我想成为那件事的天使虽然我不想告诉你为什么我认为乔是对的那件事并没有发生你只是告诉我它即将到来，我很兴奋好吧，所以我告诉你我给了你一个提示，嘿，在这一集中有一些你会喜欢的东西好吧，所以我明白这就是我的意思。
I knew I did something I did here's the real thing if this was a throwaway joke that appeared once on how I met your mother and no one ever mentioned Again, we would know one would be you be running from this joke over ownership, is because it is entered, it is in the bloodstream of every how I met your mother fan, like the major general colonel salute.
我知道我做了一些事情，我在这里做的事情是真实的，如果这是一个关于我如何遇见你母亲的一次性笑话，并且没有人提到过，我们会知道有人会因为所有权而逃避这个笑话，因为它已经进入，它已经进入了我如何遇见你母亲粉丝的血液中，就像少将上校致敬一样。
That starts this episode, by the way.
顺便说一句，这就是这一集的开始。
This is, we're talking about Slapsgiving, which is episode nine of season three.
这是我们谈论的《Slapsgiving》，这是第三季的第九集。
And I'll tell you when this, when the cold open starts, and this joke between Ted and Robin is introduced, Jordan and my wife said to me, oh, this is the, like she knew this joke, because we obviously, we do this every week.
我会告诉你，当冷门开始时，特德和罗宾之间的这个笑话被引入时，乔丹和我的妻子对我说，哦，这就是，就像她知道这个笑话一样，因为我们显然每周都会这样做。
This is the origin.
这就是起源。
This is the origin she was so happy to learn it.
这就是她学得那么高兴的由来吧。
And I will also say that, remember, we talked in season one, we got a great, unbelievable note from someone who it's going through like a 36-hour labor.
我还要说的是，记住，我们在第一季中谈过，我们从一个正在经历 36 小时分娩的人那里得到了一份很棒的、令人难以置信的留言。
And right before the kid, there was a couple that loved how I met your mother.
就在孩子之前，有一对夫妇很喜欢我和你母亲的相遇。
And the OBGYN said, "'Push, you're having a major contraction."
妇产科医生说：“用力，你正在经历严重的宫缩。”
And she turned to her husband and gave us a loot, right before her baby was born.
就在她的孩子出生之前，她转向她的丈夫，给了我们一些战利品。
That's the greatest use in history.
这是历史上最大的用途。
That's the greatest recorded use of that, right?
这是最伟大的使用记录，对吧？
Now, if women were not saluting on the birthing table, is that what you call it, in the room where their child was born, neither you nor Joel would be having this argument.
现在，如果妇女们不在分娩台上（就是你们所说的）在她们的孩子出生的房间里敬礼，那么你和乔尔都不会发生这种争论。
I'll tell you how deeply woven in.
我会告诉你它的交织有多深。
Once you get it in your head and you listeners, sweet listeners, you know that once you get this in your head, you see it everywhere.
一旦你把它记在脑子里，听众们，亲爱的听众，你知道，一旦你把它记在脑子里，你就会在任何地方看到它。
Just this morning, I almost emailed you, Craig, this morning, when I figured we would talk about it on the air.
就在今天早上，我几乎想给你发电子邮件，克雷格，当时我想我们应该在广播中讨论这件事。
Did you see Pope Leo put out a big thing about AI, 42,000 words.
你有没有看到利奥教皇发表了一篇关于人工智能的大文章，42,000字。
The New York Times says, Pope Leo's major new teaching on safeguarding humanity in the age of artificial intelligence is a forward looking document.
《纽约时报》称，教皇利奥关于在人工智能时代保护人类的重要新教义是一份前瞻性文件。
And of course I went major new teaching as they started humanity in the age of artificial intelligence.
当然，当他们在人工智能时代开启人类时，我主修了新的教学。
It really is like once it's in your bloodstream, it's very hard to unwind.
真的就像一旦进入你的血液，就很难放松。
It's a very sticky joke.
这是一个非常粘人的笑话。
That's what I think.
我就是这么认为的。
I think just, I'm gonna give you a little bit of support here, Alec, because I did, I think in another episode of this show, and I'm not gonna tell the story again, in another podcast episode, I told the story of Joel and I having a days-long battle about whether the world's strongest man competition on ESPN2 was from the late 1970s, or was current to that day.
我想，我会在这里给你一点支持，亚历克，因为我这么做了，我想在这个节目的另一集中，我不会再讲这个故事了，在另一集播客中，我讲述了乔尔和我进行了长达数天的争论的故事，争论 ESPN2 上的世界最强男子比赛是从 1970 年代末开始的，还是当时的情况。
And we had like a 72-hour argument about it where that ended with me saying I would throw myself off the roof of the campus center if I was wrong.
我们为此争论了 72 小时，最后我说如果我错了，我就会从校园中心的屋顶上跳下去。
And it turned out, and then we turned it on that night and it comes on again.
事实证明，那天晚上我们打开它，它又亮了。
It was like in reruns again, it came on, a little cairon came out and said like, 1978, I look at Joel just waiting for an apology.
就像再次重播一样，它出现了，一个小凯隆出来说，1978年，我看着乔尔只是在等待道歉。
He just goes, okay, yeah.
他只是走了，好吧，是的。
And just walked out of the room.
然后就走出了房间。
It was a marathon argument.
这是一场马拉松式的争论。
Well, it's also encapsulates, what we're doing right now is a very, how I made one other thing, which is like the fallibility of memory.
嗯，它也封装了，我们现在正在做的事情是我如何制作另一件事的，就像记忆的错误一样。
Fallibility of memory, you know.
记忆容易出错，你知道的。
Especially Joel's, yeah.
尤其是乔尔的，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
And in some ways, especially Joel's.
在某些方面，尤其是乔尔的。
This is why he didn't invite him on in person, because he would be, he would not be having this.
这就是为什么他没有亲自邀请他，因为他不会，他不会有这个。
If you're talking about a long winding story, like you have to crowdsource that.
如果你谈论的是一个漫长而曲折的故事，就像你必须众包一样。
Like it's very difficult.
好像非常困难一样。
I just read this thing, Mary Carr said about her memoir, The Liars Club, like it's not, memoir is not historical.
我刚刚读了这件事，玛丽·卡尔谈到她的回忆录《骗子俱乐部》时说，就像它不是一样，回忆录不是历史的。
Like it's not a recreated fiction.
好像这不是一部重新创作的小说。
Like it is a partisan undertaking.
就像这是一项党派事业。
Like it is a, you know, there is an agenda going on.
就像是，你知道，有一个议程正在进行。
There are things left out.
有些事情被遗漏了。
There are things amped up and amplified.
有些事情被放大和放大了。
Like it's very tricky to recreate anything.
就像重新创建任何东西都非常棘手一样。
Yes.
是的。
And Huna, I mean, okay, we'll say we'll say we'll never know.
胡娜，我的意思是，好吧，我们会说我们永远不会知道。
With a slight 51% answer, Alex.
亚历克斯的回答只有 51%。
Yeah, good, yeah.
是啊，很好，是啊。
So much love to Joel to be with us.
非常喜欢乔尔和我们在一起。
Before we get into this episode of Slapsgiving, which I actually really loved.
在我们进入这一集《Slapsgiving》之前，我真的很喜欢这一集。
I thought this was like a pop shelf, how I met your mother episode.
我觉得这就像一个流行音乐架子，《我是如何遇见你妈妈的》这一集。
I love this one of the best episodes of season three, certainly like maybe top 20.
我喜欢第三季最好的剧集之一，当然也可能是前 20 集。
It's an all-timey.
这是一个空前的。
It's really good.
真的很好。
It's an all-timey.
这是一个空前的。
It's really good.
真的很好。
But I just wanted to do some housekeeping in terms of schedule, just an update for people who are just on the edge of their seat, are Craig and Josh ever gonna have dinner.
但我只是想在日程安排方面做一些整理工作，只是向那些坐立不安的人更新一下，克雷格和乔什会吃晚饭吗？
We just wanna report just with great relief and great joy that it happened.
我们只是想以极大的欣慰和喜悦来报告这件事的发生。
Thank God.
感谢上帝。
It happened.
它发生了。
It took four months, three and a half months to four months.
花了四个月，三个半月到四个月。
We had a delightful, delightful dinner at Romans in a beautiful, beautiful dinner.
我们在罗马人餐厅吃了一顿令人愉快、愉快的晚餐，晚餐非常漂亮。
Delicious, shout out to Romans.
美味，向罗马人大喊。
Yeah, it was delicious and I learned how great Fort Green is in Brooklyn.
是的，它很美味，我了解到布鲁克林的格林堡有多棒。
You were stunned.
你惊呆了。
I couldn't believe it was the greatest.
我简直不敢相信这是最伟大的。
It was the greatest.
这是最伟大的。
We walked Nelson, Nelson, who sometimes cameos, Josh's dog, sometimes cameos on the pod over Josh's shoulder, looking out the window longingly to wanting to go on the walk that I've now been on with him.
我们带着纳尔逊散步，纳尔逊有时会客串乔什的狗，有时会客串在乔什肩上的吊舱上，渴望地看着窗外，想要继续我现在和他一起散步的路。
And it is a lovely walk.
这是一次愉快的散步。
It's that is a gorgeous area.
这是一个美丽的地区。
I really had never spent any time there.
我真的从来没有在那里呆过任何时间。
It was just, in the two blocks around you was like 18 great spots to go out from.
只是，在你周围的两个街区里，有 18 个适合外出的好地方。
I know, I kept pointing out, like, each restaurant that was on last.
我知道，我一直指出最后的每家餐厅。
Well, I think Manhattanites, certain ones, like you, Craig, you're just, you're sleeping on Brooklyn.
嗯，我认为曼哈顿人，某些人，比如你，克雷格，你只是睡在布鲁克林。
We're snobs, we are snobs, I know.
我们是势利小人，我们是势利小人，我知道。
Yeah, it's not the 1990s anymore, my friend.
是的，现在已经不是 20 世纪 90 年代了，我的朋友。
I wonder if, we never said what part of Brooklyn Kobe was in.
我想知道我们是否从未说过科比在布鲁克林的哪一部分。
I don't think maybe she, maybe she was friend of Fort Crane.
我想也许她不是，也许她是克莱恩堡的朋友。
Maybe look at that Kobe, Robin, the character's name.
也许看看科比、罗宾这个角色的名字。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay.
好的。
But we had a great dinner.
但我们吃了一顿丰盛的晚餐。
We had a great dinner.
我们吃了一顿丰盛的晚餐。
Craig, around the dessert line, Craig got very amorous with you.
克雷格，在吃甜点的时候，克雷格对你非常有好感。
I got very amorous, a little handsy.
我变得非常多情，有点手巧。
A little handsy.
有点方便。
We had a great time.
我们玩得很开心。
glad we were able to make that work.
很高兴我们能够做到这一点。
Also, I just got back from Rio, where my wife's brother, Gabe, got married to his beloved Isa in Rio.
另外，我刚刚从里约回来，我妻子的兄弟加布在里约与他心爱的伊莎结婚了。
Congrats.
恭喜。
And what a destination wedding.
真是一场目的地婚礼。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
We couldn't miss it.
我们不能错过它。
And we took our son who did as well as a seven month old could do, you know, this long.
我们带着我们的儿子，他已经做到了一个七个月大的孩子所能做到的，你知道，这么长时间。
How long is that play?
那场戏要多长时间？
Well, first we connected through Atlanta and then flew to Rio and on the way back we flew Rio to Miami.
嗯，首先我们经亚特兰大转机，然后飞往里约，在回来的路上我们又飞往里约热内卢飞往迈阿密。
They were, you know, the long stretches were nine, ten hours, but he did great.
你知道，很长的一段时间有九、十个小时，但他表现得很好。
We're really happy to be home, but I have to say two things about this Rio wedding.
我们很高兴回到家，但关于这次里约婚礼我不得不说两件事。
One, I love Brazil.
第一，我爱巴西。
It was my third time there.
这是我第三次去那里。
Let's go out to the Brazilian fans of our mother.
让我们去找我们母亲的巴西粉丝吧。
I met a lot of Brazilian fans of the show, but I also have to say our friend Alex is married to a Brazilian woman named Luana, they're very dear friends of ours, and they split their time between New York and Rio, and they said, our nanny is the best down there.
我遇到了很多巴西的节目粉丝，但我也不得不说，我们的朋友亚历克斯嫁给了一位名叫卢安娜的巴西女人，他们是我们非常亲密的朋友，他们在纽约和里约热内卢之间度过了时间，他们说，我们的保姆是那里最好的。
Like you've got, we needed some, you know, assistance so we could, you know, go places.
就像你们一样，我们需要一些帮助，这样我们就可以去一些地方。
So Isabella, this wonderful, wonderful nanny down in Rio was watching our son for a part of the time.
所以，伊莎贝拉，这位住在里约热内卢的非常非常好的保姆，有一段时间一直在照顾我们的儿子。
We got immediately, like we were there six days.
我们很快就到了，就像我们在那里呆了六天一样。
We felt so close to her, but when we were leaving, she said, Josh, can I, can I say one thing too?
我们感觉和她很亲近，但是当我们离开时，她说，乔希，我可以，我也可以说一件事吗？
And I said, sure.
我说，当然。
And she said, I love your show.
她说，我喜欢你的节目。
I learned English from watching your show.
我通过看你的节目学会了英语。
And I was such an honor to meet you and work with you this weekend.
我很荣幸在这个周末见到你并与你一起工作。
It was just so sweet.
真是太甜蜜了。
So shout out to Isabella.
所以向伊莎贝拉大声喊叫。
She always said it at the very end.
她总是在最后才说这句话。
She said it at the very end, very idea.
她最后说的，很有想法。
That's also very cool somehow.
这在某种程度上也很酷。
Very sweet, very sweet.
很甜很甜。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
Hey, Greg, since we had dinner, any life updates?
嘿，格雷格，我们吃过晚饭后，有什么生活更新吗？
Oh boy, any life updates?
天啊，有什么生活更新吗？
Let me think, the dinner was the highlight of my fucking month, are you kidding?
让我想一想，晚餐是我他妈的这个月的亮点，你在开玩笑吗？
That was it.
就是这样。
Now my daughter's playing saxophone, my son's playing the drums, we got a big salads concert for Hamish and Mother coming up on June 20th, but this will probably be long over.
现在我的女儿正在吹萨克斯管，我的儿子正在打鼓，我们将于 6 月 20 日为哈米什和母亲举办一场大型沙拉音乐会，但这可能会结束很久。
That will be long over by the time this happens.
到这件事发生时，那已经过去很久了。
But yeah, the music thing, man, music is magic.
但是，是的，音乐是有魔力的。
Music is magic.
音乐是有魔力的。
I figured out how to play guitar with my daughter, and I figured out where to capo the guitar to be in the same key as her saxophone, which I didn't know for a while.
我弄清楚了如何和我的女儿一起弹吉他，我也弄清楚了吉他变调夹的位置，使其与她的萨克斯管处于同一调，这是我有一段时间不知道的。
And you put the capo on the third foot of the guitar, you were very much in C with that saxophone.
当你把变调夹放在吉他的第三个脚上时，你就可以用萨克斯管演奏 C 调了。
Oh, that's cool.
哦，那太酷了。
And it's very cool with that she has an alto sax, and we are doing family bands, like two or three nights a week where we're all jamming, and it's like, I become Marshall.
她有一把中音萨克斯管，这非常酷，我们正在组建家庭乐队，每周有两到三个晚上我们都会即兴演奏，就像，我变成了马歇尔。
I'm basically becoming Marshall Erickson, the family band thing, and it's fantastic.
我基本上正在成为马歇尔·埃里克森（Marshall Erickson），家庭乐队的事情，这太棒了。
That's so cool.
太酷了。
Well, this episode fittingly ends with a great song.
好吧，这一集以一首美妙的歌曲恰如其分地结束了。
We'll get to that.
我们会解决这个问题的。
It does.
确实如此。
But this episode was written by whom?
但这一段话是由谁写的呢？
Was this a Bays and Thomas episode?
这是贝斯和托马斯的一集吗？
This is an episode written by Matt Coon.
这是马特·库恩撰写的一集。
This was his second episode.
这是他的第二集。
He wrote for the show.
他为节目写作。
He wrote columns in season two.
他在第二季撰写专栏。
This was the first one that I kind of got to be paired as like the, this was my episode with him.
这是我第一次像这样配对，这是我和他的一集。
Carter and I would divide and conquer on episodes.
卡特和我会在剧集中分而治之。
And it was just so great to see someone who was our writer assistant or perhaps script coordinator at that time.
很高兴见到当时担任我们编剧助理或剧本协调员的人。
I forget what his title is.
我忘记他的头衔是什么了。
Just making this big leap and writing this great all-timer episode, it was such a delight.
刚刚实现这一巨大飞跃并写下这一伟大的历史性剧集，真是令人高兴。
I loved when we got to give those opportunities to the many wonderful people who worked on the show with us.
我很高兴我们能够为与我们一起工作的许多优秀人员提供这些机会。
Was he already at that point doing Barney's blog and doing the Barney books?
那时他是否已经开始制作巴尼的博客并制作巴尼的书籍了？
Yes, he mad.
是的，他生气了。
Because he really wrote almost all of those, right?
因为几乎所有这些都是他写的，对吗？
He did.
他做到了。
He was the main voice of Barney off network.
他是巴尼网外的主要配音。
He headed up writing the Barney Bro code books that were sort of a spinoff from writing these great Barney's blog entries every week on CBS.com.
他负责编写《巴尼兄弟》代码书，这本书是每周在 CBS.com 上撰写这些精彩的巴尼博客文章的副产品。
was a Barney's blog sort of on theme with the with the episode.
是巴尼的博客，主题与这一集有关。
And he was just he showed so much just hustle.
他只是表现出了如此多的忙碌。
He just like did all of those things that we needed done often for no money.
他喜欢做我们经常需要做的所有事情，但不花钱。
Sometimes it was like a little money in it.
有时就像里面有一点钱。
But he was he really just did that thing.
但他确实只是做了那件事。
We've talked about many times, Josh, of just like he just loved doing the work and he wanted to do a great job at every single thing and raised his hand to do extracurricular stuff.
乔什，我们已经谈过很多次了，就像他喜欢做这份工作，他想把每件事都做得很好，并举手去做课外的事情。
And he became a writer.
他成为了一名作家。
It's so cool when you're on a long running show, when you see people rise from like, you know, stapling together the scripts into like being a co-executive producer, being on set, pitching jokes, like, and also, you know, just a shout out to the WGA and they're really fighting against these trimmed writing staffs, not allowing the writers to be on set.
当你在一个长时间运行的节目中，当你看到人们从像联合执行制片人那样把剧本拼凑在一起，在片场，讲笑话，就像，而且，你知道，只是向 WGA 大声喊叫时，他们真的在与这些精简的编剧人员作斗争，不允许编剧在片场，这真是太酷了。
We've talked about this, but like, I've seen up close, like, how you apprentice and great verb apprentice.
我们已经讨论过这个，但是就像，我近距离地看到了，就像，你是如何学徒的，以及伟大的动词学徒。
Yeah, He was an apprentice, like, but almost like in the old tiny sense of like, you'd apprentice with a cobbler, you'd apprentice with someone to learn a trade.
是的，他是一个学徒，但几乎就像在古老的微小意义上一样，你会和一个鞋匠一起学徒，你会和某人一起学一门手艺。
Get your 10,000 hours.
获得 10,000 小时。
Yeah.
是的。
Get it in.
把它放进去。
Talk about the Beatles.
谈论披头士乐队。
Like, get in there.
就像，进去吧。
Play a bunch of covers in Hamburg.
在汉堡演奏一堆翻唱歌曲。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the Germany.
那就是德国。
And he, so he did, he was on all nine seasons of how much mother started and as a registrant and then worked his way all the way up to CoEP.
他也确实这么做了，他参加了《妈妈有多好》的全部九季，并作为一名注册者，然后一直努力到 CoEP。
This is his first episode and what a great entryway.
这是他的第一集，也是一个很棒的入口。
It is such a great, I really, really love this episode.
太棒了，我真的非常喜欢这一集。
Yeah.
是的。
A lot.
很多。
Alec, tell us when this episode aired.
亚历克，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出。
This was November 19th, 2007, right around Thanksgiving time.
那是 2007 年 11 月 19 日，感恩节前后。
All right.
好的。
And Craig, I would say this is both an episode of this was your first episode of How I Met Your Mother.
克雷格，我想说这既是你的《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的第一集。
You get it pretty quickly.
你很快就明白了。
But also, if you've been with the show, it rewards your fidelity.
而且，如果你参加过这个节目，它也会奖励你的忠诚度。
It rewards longtime viewers, most, especially with the slap that, which is one of the great runners in the whole show.
它奖励了长期观看的观众，尤其是那一巴掌，这是整个节目中最伟大的跑步者之一。
Koon absolutely crushed it with the script.
库恩用剧本彻底粉碎了它。
It was fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah, this was one.
是的，这就是其中之一。
This was maybe my favorite one of season three and one of my all time favorites.
这可能是我第三季中最喜欢的一季，也是我一直以来的最爱之一。
And it, I think the reason it works, obviously, it starts with this really funny, ridiculous Alec and Joel, whoever came up with a joke.
我认为它起作用的原因显然是从这个非常有趣、可笑的亚历克和乔尔开始的，无论是谁想出了一个笑话。
I thought, I sort of thought of the emotional core of this episode because of the saluting thing.
我想，因为致敬的事情，我有点想到了这一集的情感核心。
And I'll explain that idea that happens at the end where that idea of friendship is reflexive, that idea occurred to me because of the saluting thing.
我将解释最后发生的想法，其中友谊的想法是反射性的，因为敬礼的事情而产生了这个想法。
Because Josh, just like you said, if you go all in on this joke, it becomes reflexive to you.
因为乔什，就像你说的，如果你全力以赴地听这个笑话，它就会成为你的条件反射。
You will do it while you're giving birth for crying out loud.
当你分娩时，你会因大声哭泣而这样做。
And I thought of that idea just occurred to me and this seemed like the perfect example of it.
我想到了我刚刚想到的这个想法，这似乎是一个完美的例子。
We wanted you to know episode where 10 Robin really are having a hard time being friends.
我们想让你知道 10 罗宾很难成为朋友的那一集。
And I love how we planted the seeds of that.
我喜欢我们播下这颗种子的方式。
In a few of the earlier episodes of season three, it's weird, they broke up.
在第三季的前几集中，很奇怪，他们分手了。
They're trying to pretend they're still great friends, but are they?
他们试图假装他们仍然是好朋友，但他们是吗？
Robin is now bringing a new guy to friend Thanksgiving that they're having.
罗宾现在要带一个新朋友来参加朋友的感恩节。
It is weird, it's weird to Ted, they have been distant.
这很奇怪，对特德来说很奇怪，他们一直很疏远。
And we wanted to show an episode where they seriously consider not being friends anymore, and then something brings them back, something reflexive, something comes at them that just is undeniable and evocative of their deeper connection that they're supposed to still be in each other's lives.
我们想展示这样一集，他们认真考虑不再是朋友了，然后有些东西让他们回来，一些本能的东西来到他们身边，这是不可否认的，唤起他们更深层次的联系，他们应该仍然存在于彼此的生活中。
And somehow that was the big core of this episode that happened kind of right away.
不知何故，这就是这一集的核心内容，并且马上就发生了。
That was the big idea of this episode right away.
这就是本集的大创意。
Craig, I wrote down friendship as an involuntary reflex, which is what the narrator tells us.
克雷格，我把友谊写成一种不自觉的反射，这就是叙述者告诉我们的。
Right, right, right, friendship.
对对对，友情。
Yeah, that's what we said.
是的，我们就是这么说的。
Involuntary reflex.
不自觉的反射。
And I thought, you know, it startled me because it's such a smart line.
我想，你知道，这让我很惊讶，因为这是一条非常聪明的线路。
It's such an insightful line.
这是一条很有洞察力的路线。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's also, again, it's in a sitcom on CBS on Monday night.
但这也再次出现在周一晚上哥伦比亚广播公司的情景喜剧中。
That could be in a Joyce Carol Oates short story.
这可能出现在乔伊斯·卡罗尔·奥茨的短篇小说中。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like, yes.
就像，是的。
And it's better than I just said it.
而且比我刚才说的要好。
It's how paraphrased it works.
这就是它的解释方式。
But the thought is really powerful.
但这个想法确实很强大。
And it's a very mature thought.
这是一个非常成熟的想法。
I know the mature character is saying it, but you created a context or a structure where wisdom could seep through.
我知道成熟的角色会这么说，但你创造了一个可以渗透智慧的背景或结构。
You know, that's what I think people like about the show.
你知道，我认为这就是人们喜欢这个节目的原因。
They get to see people having too many sandwiches or waking up next to someone they don't know all the folly of being in your late 20s and mid 20s.
他们会看到人们吃太多三明治，或者在一个他们不认识的人身边醒来，这些都是二十多岁和二十多岁的愚蠢行为。
But you also have this wisdom and reflection and it's contextualized as like, these were important parts of my life.
但你也有这种智慧和反思，它的背景就像，这些是我生活的重要组成部分。
This is what I learned.
这是我学到的。
I'll say two things, both courtesy of my wife, when the cold open was done, I think when the credits sequence start, she just turned to me, she said, I love this show.
我要说两件事，都是出于我妻子的礼貌，当冷场结束时，我想当演职员表开始时，她只是转向我，她说，我喜欢这个节目。
I just thought it was so, it's like, and she also said, we were talking about how easy they go down, and how you can see when, it used to startle me when people say, I've watched the show 15 times, and I'm like, wait, what do you mean?
我只是觉得是这样，就像，她还说，我们正在谈论他们是多么容易失败，以及你如何看到什么时候，当人们说，我已经看了这个节目 15 遍时，我常常感到震惊，我想，等等，你是什么意思？
How do you have the time?
你怎么有时间？
But the truth is, you can binge this show pretty quick.
但事实是，你可以很快地看完这个节目。
Like my niece is in nephews, like watch this show pretty quick.
就像我的侄女在侄子里一样，喜欢快速观看这个节目。
Like, you can watch it and if you love it, you can re-watch it, it really goes down smooth.
就像，你可以观看它，如果你喜欢它，你可以重新观看它，它真的很顺利。
But also, Jordana was, she said, I'm so glad they're dealing with Ted and Robin still hanging out all the time together.
而且，乔丹娜说，我很高兴他们能和泰德和罗宾打交道，他们仍然一直在一起闲逛。
Like, she felt like it was kind of in certain episodes, this thing wasn't highlighted.
就像，她觉得在某些剧集中，这件事没有被强调。
It just looked like they went from being in a relationship to them being friends, which is obviously tricky, unless you're kind of divorced your emotional life, which neither of them are.
看起来他们从恋爱关系变成了朋友，这显然很棘手，除非你脱离了你的情感生活，而他们都没有。
So she was really grateful that you guys were squarely journeying into the storm of this.
所以她真的很感激你们能直接踏入这场风暴。
Yeah, me too.
是的，我也是。
I'm really glad we brought that back up.
我真的很高兴我们重新提起了这一点。
We kind of touched upon it the first couple episodes of season three, end of episode two especially.
我们在第三季的前几集，尤其是第二集的结尾部分谈到了它。
And then it was kind of like, now they're okay and that's not really how life works, right?
然后有点像，现在他们没事了，但这并不是生活的真正方式，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
You can say now we're okay and move on And it cannot be true.
你可以说现在我们一切都好并继续前进但这不可能是真的。
It can turn out not to be true.
事实可能并非如此。
And Thanksgiving felt like a good way to say like, wait, we're all gonna have this Thanksgiving together and Robin's bringing this new guy who is, and we got to say the great.
感恩节感觉是一个很好的方式来表达，等等，我们要一起过这个感恩节，罗宾带来了这个新人，我们必须说太棒了。
This episode does so many things that are the best things about him, the fallibility of memory, the how I remember this guy.
这一集做了很多关于他最好的事情，记忆的错误，以及我如何记住这个人。
It's kind of like with blah, blah.
这有点像“blah, blah”。
I remember this guy was for a handsome 41-year-old athletic guy played by Evan, one of our stand-ins from the show.
我记得这个人是一个 41 岁的英俊运动员，由埃文扮演，他是剧中的替身之一。
Shout out to Evan.
向埃文大声喊叫。
as shout out to Evan, but I remember him like this and that it's Orson Bean, who are huge fans.
向埃文大声喊叫，但我记得他是这样的，而且是奥森·比恩，他是他的超级粉丝。
He was like a TV fixture.
他就像电视里的固定装置。
He was on like, he is a hilarious guy.
他就像，他是一个搞笑的人。
He was on all these like game shows and talk shows.
他参加了所有这些游戏节目和脱口秀节目。
He was like one of those kind of guys in the 60s.
他就像 60 年代的那种人之一。
And then he had that amazing turn in being John Malkovich as John Kuzak's like really crazy and seemingly ancient boss in being John Malkovich.
然后他在扮演约翰·马尔科维奇时发生了惊人的转变，因为约翰·库扎克在扮演约翰·马尔科维奇时就像非常疯狂且看似古老的老板。
He's so funny and peculiar and unique that we've targeted him, it has to be him.
他是如此有趣、奇特和独特，以至于我们瞄准了他，必须是他。
He's so funny in this episode.
他在这一集中非常有趣。
I will say, I do need to apologize for the ages I'm on the show now that we're in.
我想说，我确实需要为我在节目中呆了这么久而道歉。
We've got to talk about this.
我们得谈谈这个。
Because I am not comfortable with it.
因为我对此感到不舒服。
Well, but I will say just you have certain memories.
好吧，但我会说只有你有某些记忆。
You know, we talk a lot about, we tell people you'd get big laughs of the table read, maybe big laughs of the network studio run through, big laugh the first time you rehearse it for the crew, and then it's diminishing returns mostly.
你知道，我们谈论了很多，我们告诉人们你会在读表时大笑，也许在网络演播室运行时会大笑，第一次为剧组排练时会大笑，然后大部分都是收益递减。
By the last take, no one's ever thinking about lunch.
到最后一次拍摄时，没有人想到午餐。
People are, you know, they're phone, yeah.
人们，你知道，他们是电话，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
But Orson Bean, my memory is laughter on every take.
但是奥森·比恩，我的记忆是每一次拍摄时都充满笑声。
Every take.
每一次拍摄。
Every take, he just crushed.
每一次拍摄，他都被压垮了。
So funny.
太有趣了。
He was so funny and he threw it all away in the perfect way.
他太有趣了，他以完美的方式把一切都扔掉了。
There was a lot of stuff.
有很多东西。
There's a bad way to do that role.
扮演这个角色的方法很糟糕。
Like there's a, he let himself be the joke and he played it like pretty straight.
就像有一个，他让自己成为一个笑话，而且他表现得很直接。
Which is like so much funnier.
这真是太有趣了。
so much fun, like tried to amp it up and be.
太有趣了，就像试图放大它一样。
Yeah, he just was.
是的，他就是这样。
He's so funny, R.I.P, who we've lost him since then, he's great.
他很有趣，R.I.P，从那以后我们就失去了他，他很棒。
Oh, I didn't know that.
哦，我不知道。
He was Phil Lord's neighbor at one point in Venice and Phil, I'm gonna be like, oh yeah, I see Orson B and all the time down at the beach in Venice, which I was like, that is a cool neighbor to have.
他曾经是 Phil Lord 在威尼斯的邻居，而 Phil，我会说，哦，是的，我看到 Orson B，一直在威尼斯的海滩上，我当时想，这是一个很酷的邻居。
Orson B in Venice.
奥森 B 在威尼斯。
Yeah.
是的。
He's just, he was a character that guy and he was very, very funny, but the 41 year old joke is not aging well for me.
他只是，他就是那个家伙，他非常非常有趣，但这个 41 年前的笑话对我来说不太适合。
In some ways though, you guys were on to yourself because even though when there's always a flash forward and Marshall's 42, you make him like 6,000.
但在某些方面，你们是在做自己，因为尽管总是有闪现，马歇尔是 42 分，但你们却让他得到了 6,000 分。
He's a hundred and sixty-two years old.
他今年一百六十二岁了。
But you guys in some ways were calling attention to, oh, this happened to be yesterday in the airport in Miami.
但你们以某种方式提请注意，哦，这恰好是昨天在迈阿密机场发生的事情。
I'm getting a cup of coffee and these two, I think they were in college, these girls behind me.
我正在喝杯咖啡，这两个人，我想她们正在上大学，我身后的这些女孩。
They- I'm nervous.
他们——我很紧张。
I don't even know what's gonna happen when I'm nervous.
我什至不知道当我紧张的时候会发生什么。
It says, one of them says, Um, my, uh, my brother is like always dating these older girls and like, he's 23 and he was dating this 28 year old.
上面说，其中一个人说，嗯，我的，呃，我的兄弟总是和这些年长的女孩约会，比如，他 23 岁，和这个 28 岁的女孩约会。
And she said, well, I want to get, we should get married because I want to have a baby and it's like, I'm only 23.
她说，好吧，我想结婚，我们应该结婚，因为我想生个孩子，而我才 23 岁。
And so he broke up with her.
于是他和她分手了。
And my older sister is 26 and she's dating a 30 year old because she likes older guys.
我姐姐 26 岁，正在和一个 30 岁的人约会，因为她喜欢年长的男人。
And then she literally said, can you imagine 30?
然后她真的说，你能想象30个吗？
Oh no.
哦不。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And I'm like standing, I'm in front of them at, you know, 51.
我就像站着，我站在他们面前，你知道，51 号。
Oh, looking like a decent, like I'm holding it together, but I was also like, I felt like the Crip Keepers dad, you know?
哦，看起来很体面，就像我把它放在一起一样，但我也觉得，我觉得自己像瘸子守护者的爸爸，你知道吗？
Not the Crip Keepers dad.
不是瘸子守护者的爸爸。
That's a great turn of phrase.
这是一个很好的措辞转变。
That was a matter of time.
这是时间问题。
But it also shows you like when you're 22.
但它也显示了你22岁时的喜好。
Yeah.
是的。
30 is ancient.
30是古代。
41.
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
Well, look at us fucking little shitting.
好吧，看看我们他妈的小屎。
Are you picking out your grave plot?
你在挑选你的墓地吗？
We're like 32 writing that 41 looked like Orson Bean.
我们就像 32 人写的那样，41 人看起来像奥森·比恩。
And Orson Bean looked great for whatever age he was, but we were a little dicks of that age.
奥森·比恩无论在什么年龄，看起来都很棒，但我们在那个年龄段却是个小混蛋。
But you also acknowledge by the storyline itself, you acknowledge that two or 28 year old 41 can look.
但你也承认故事情节本身，你承认2岁或28岁41岁可以看。
Right, and Robin also says why are you, and also Ted is jealous and upset, Ted is jealous, Ted is choosing to view this guy as ancient to cushion.
是的，罗宾也说你为什么是这样，泰德也嫉妒和不安，泰德嫉妒，泰德选择将这个家伙视为古老的人来缓冲。
Yeah, also Jordana said to me, she goes, that's our age difference, which is 13 years.
是的，乔丹娜也对​​我说，她说，这就是我们的年龄差，13 岁。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Yeah, so we had a lot of fun with that one.
是的，所以我们玩得很开心。
But he was fantastic and the whole joke is great.
但他太棒了，整个笑话也很棒。
I mean, part of this, the reason I think this episode, I really like looking at when the show is firing on all cylinders, why it's working so well.
我的意思是，部分原因是我认为这一集，我真的很喜欢看这部剧什么时候火力全开，为什么它运作得这么好。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
I think one Thanksgiving is a perfect setting for this because Thanksgiving is when the nerve endings are raw and like it's a time of togetherness, but it's also often the time of conflict is the time where things get said that maybe might not otherwise get said or it's a very provocative time.
我认为感恩节是一个完美的背景，因为感恩节是神经末梢处于原始状态的时候，就像是团聚的时刻，但它也常常是冲突的时刻，是一些可能不会说出来的事情被说出的时刻，或者这是一个非常挑衅的时刻。
Yes, so I love the setting.
是的，所以我喜欢这个设置。
I love, I think that how I make your mother's best when it's bar and apartments.
我喜欢，我认为当我在酒吧和公寓时，我如何让你母亲变得最好。
Me too.
我也是。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's like when it's on its home turf, it somehow is like.
就像当它在自己的地盘上时一样。
Because everything in the universe can be contained in those, if you tell the story right, you don't need anything more.
因为宇宙中的一切都可以包含在其中，如果你正确地讲述故事，你不需要更多的东西。
You can find infinity in those couple of sets and you can find, you don't need to do all of these bells and whistles in other locations.
你可以在这几组中找到无限，你会发现，你不需要在其他地方做所有这些花里胡哨的事情。
Yeah, it actually preserves the core energy somehow.
是的，它实际上以某种方式保留了核心能量。
But you have the A story between Ted and Robin is like incredibly emotional.
但泰德和罗宾之间的故事非常感人。
It's incredibly on brand in terms of Ted trying to figure out his romantic life.
泰德试图弄清楚他的浪漫生活，这是令人难以置信的品牌。
And then the B story, I would say, the slap is just like one of the most delightfully, like it's the comedic motor of the slap and the five slaps and when is the next slap gonna come.
然后是 B 故事，我想说，这一巴掌就像是最令人愉快的故事之一，就像是这一巴掌和五巴掌的喜剧动力，以及下一次巴掌何时到来。
and Marshall's absolute glee in taunting Barney and Neil, and Neil's like terror.
马歇尔在嘲笑巴尼和尼尔时表现得非常高兴，而尼尔则感到恐惧。
And he did something like where he pictured it in his eye like twitch.
他做了一些事情，就像他在眼睛里想象的那样抽搐。
It was amazing.
太棒了。
It looked like a cartoon.
它看起来像卡通片。
Do you know what I'm talking about?
你知道我在说什么吗？
I know exactly what you mean.
我完全明白你的意思。
Yeah, this quivering lip and eye and cheek, it was, it was, and his bravado that you ruined it, but it turns out he didn't ruin it.
是的，这个颤抖的嘴唇、眼睛和脸颊，是的，是的，还有他的虚张声势，你毁了它，但事实证明他并没有毁掉它。
It's even worse knowing that it's going to happen.
更糟糕的是知道这将会发生。
Like everyone had an arc.
就像每个人都有弧线一样。
Even in those stupid little things, there was like an ABC, there was like points in the story, right?
即使在那些愚蠢的小事中，也有像ABC一样的故事情节，对吧？
There's like an emotional through line for everybody.
每个人都有一条情感贯穿线。
Like Lily is really mama bear in this episode.
就像莉莉在这一集中真的是熊妈妈一样。
She's both the slap at commissioner, which is like a mama bear role.
她既是专员的一巴掌，就像熊妈妈的角色。
And also like trying to create this nice thing, and they're first, they're first friends together, which is a big fucking deal, right?
也喜欢尝试创造这个美好的东西，他们是第一个，他们是第一个在一起的朋友，这真是一件大事，对吧？
And she wants it to go out.
她希望它出去。
That's the other stakes of the episode.
这是这一集的其他利害关系。
She's trying to create a tradition.
她正在努力创造一种传统。
Right.
正确的。
It's very sad when Marshall says, we're going to do this every year, right?
当马歇尔说我们每年都会这样做时，我感到非常难过，对吗？
After we've just heard Ted and Ramana green, not to be friends anymore.
我们刚刚听说泰德和拉玛纳绿了，不再是朋友了。
It's really sad.
真的很难过。
It just, there's so many emotional moments in this.
只是，这里面有很多情感时刻。
It's also very chosen.
也是很有选择的。
This episode's very chosen family episode.
本集是精心挑选的家庭剧集。
Like, why aren't they with their families?
比如，他们为什么不和家人在一起？
Yeah, it's chosen family.
是的，这是选择的家庭。
And also, like, think about how the religious dogma of this friend group, the incredibly intricate or innate religious dogma, the rules of the slap bet, the major general kernel thing, the incredibly like Byzantine or innate sort of inner logic, this other language that this friend group has developed, the whole episode is about that.
而且，想想这个朋友团体的宗教教条，极其复杂或天生的宗教教条，打赌的规则，主要的一般核心事物，令人难以置信的拜占庭式或天生的内在逻辑，这个朋友团体开发的另一种语言，整个情节都是关于这些的。
It's about their language.
这是关于他们的语言。
It's their vernacular.
这是他们的方言。
They're getting about like creating mythology, their own mythology.
他们正在创造神话，他们自己的神话。
Yes.
是的。
It's the mythology of this group.
这是这个团体的神话。
It's the native tongue of this group.
这是这个群体的母语。
And nobody else speaks quite like them.
没有人能像他们一样说话。
No one else has these inside jokes.
没有人有这些内部笑话。
And here we're at risk of losing some part of this group or what's gonna happen to this whole group and that's the stakes of the episode.
在这里，我们面临着失去这个群体的某些部分的风险，或者整个群体会发生什么，这就是这一集的赌注。
what's gonna happen are these jokes are all gonna scatter to the wind like dandelion spores.
将会发生的是，这些笑话都会像蒲公英孢子一样散落到风中。
That's another reason I think this episode works.
这是我认为这一集有效的另一个原因。
It's like, I don't know if it's chicken or egg, like things are extra funny when, no, I would say that's probably a comedic truth.
就像，我不知道这是先有鸡还是先有蛋，当事情变得特别有趣时，不，我会说这可能是一个喜剧真相。
Things are funnier when the stakes are higher.
当赌注更高时，事情会更有趣。
And when there's real sadness along the way.
当一路上有真正的悲伤时。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
I believe that wholeheartedly.
我全心全意地相信这一点。
Like the absurdity of the slap, which is so simple.
就像一巴掌的荒唐，就是这么简单。
It's like Buster Heaton simple.
这就像巴斯特·希顿一样简单。
like a shout out to Alakula, I suppose you're getting out today.
就像向阿拉库拉喊叫一样，我想你今天就出去了。
You take the smallest little premise and you just explore it from every nook and cranny.
你选择最小的前提，然后从每一个角落和缝隙中探索它。
But underneath it, parallel alongside it is one of the elements of the gang, of this five person perfectly structured into something is possibly going to be extracted.
但在它的下面，与它平行的是该团伙的成员之一，这五个人完美地构造成某种可能会被提取出来的东西。
Like it's really heartbreaking.
好像真的很让人心碎。
Yeah.
是的。
And Robin and Ted are the only ones that know it.
只有罗宾和泰德知道这一点。
And Marshall's giving a toast saying we're all gonna do this for years to come.
马歇尔举杯祝酒，表示我们将在未来几年继续这样做。
And it's really sad.
这真的很难过。
And it's really deeply sad and then deeply moving that they, without ever talking about it explicitly, we see them decide to be friends via this amazing inside joke that Joel invented in their, and Alec's a great group.
我们看到他们决定通过乔尔在他们中发明的这个惊人的内部笑话成为朋友，而亚历克是一个伟大的团队，这真的非常令人悲伤，然后又令人深受感动。
Hi, I'm just wanted to see if Alec is still paying.
嗨，我只是想看看亚历克是否还在付款。
He's gonna cut that out, he's gonna cut that out.
他要把它剪掉，他要把它剪掉。
I also just wanna just add, by the way that you've, you define this familial world that you've created with their codes of their logic of everything.
我还想补充一点，顺便说一下，你定义了这个你用他们的一切逻辑代码创建的家庭世界。
And then what's wild, of course, is you've given that to the world who writes to us by the thousands that they use the same, they use those codes.
当然，最疯狂的是，你已经向世界提供了成千上万的人写信给我们，他们使用相同的代码，他们使用这些代码。
They use those languages in their friends circles.
他们在朋友圈中使用这些语言。
Also, you've sort of given that out.
而且，你已经把它给了出来。
It's extraordinary.
这是非凡的。
It's global, it's gone global.
它是全球性的，它已经全球化了。
If you speak that language on, say, a dating site, and someone else speaks that language, they will flag you.
如果你在约会网站上说这种语言，而其他人也说这种语言，他们就会标记你。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
We've heard it.
我们听说过。
People get married because they like the Joel's joke.
人们结婚是因为他们喜欢乔尔的笑话。
Yeah, they like Joel's joke.
是的，他们喜欢乔尔的笑话。
Wait, it keeps happening.
等等，这样的事情一直在发生。
Or they just, there's a kind of thing like, you're a little bit pre-approved.
或者他们只是，有一种事情，比如，你有点预先批准了。
Like if you love how I met your mother so much and you meet someone you're attracted to who loves how I met your mother so much, that is shorthand for a very particular kind of thing.
就像如果你非常喜欢我与你母亲的相遇，而你遇到了一个你所吸引的人，他也非常喜欢我与你母亲的相遇，这是一种非常特殊的事情的简写。
It's friendship is an involuntary reflex.
它的友谊是一种不自觉的反射。
Like it is that, it's that thing.
就像是那样，就是那样的东西。
And I like that we see Ted and Robin try to throw their friendship away and it doesn't take.
我喜欢看到泰德和罗宾试图抛弃他们的友谊，但这并不需要。
They take this friendship and they say we're throwing it, we're going to drown this friendship in the East River and it doesn't want to go.
他们拿走了这段友谊，他们说我们要把它扔掉，我们要把这段友谊淹没在东河里，但它不想走。
It comes back around.
它又回来了。
It's like a horror movie but a very happy horror movie that the friendship is like, nope, I'm coming back.
这就像一部恐怖电影，但却是一部非常快乐的恐怖电影，友谊就像是，不，我回来了。
You tried to kill me but there's something here that is unkillable and we're going to stay friends because of this stupid joke because we speak the same language and I love that moment.
你想杀了我，但这里有一些杀不死的东西，因为这个愚蠢的笑话，我们将保持朋友关系，因为我们说着同样的语言，我喜欢那一刻。
You and Colby are fantastic in this episode and fantastic in that moment.
你和科尔比在这一集中表现得很棒，在那一刻也很棒。
I watched it with my wife Rebecca and I could tell she got very moved by that moment.
我和我的妻子丽贝卡一起观看了这部电影，我可以看出她对那一刻非常感动。
It just clicked for her watching.
她看着就点击了。
I could just feel it.
我能感觉到。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, it's also really nice that it starts off as this quirky, silly signifier of how and mesh they are in it and noise their friends until their friends start doing it because it's such a sticky joke, and then it turns out to be the very sweet touching thing that ends the episode and lets us know it's going to be okay.
嗯，这也很好，一开始就是这个古怪、愚蠢的标志，表明他们在其中如何融入，并吵闹他们的朋友，直到他们的朋友开始这样做，因为这是一个粘性的笑话，然后结果是一个非常甜蜜感人的事情结束了这一集，让我们知道一切都会好起来的。
And it infects the whole group like an outbreak movie, the group is finally starting to do it involuntarily themselves.
它像一部爆发电影一样感染了整个团体，团体终于开始不由自主地自己这样做。
We don't say who came up with it, Ted or Robin.
我们没有说谁想出了这个主意，是泰德还是罗宾。
See Alec, it doesn't matter, you and Joel don't need to argue, it's just sort of born out of nowhere, Ted and Robin just start doing and it's a connection, does it really matter who invented it really?
瞧，亚历克，没关系，你和乔尔不需要争论，它只是凭空诞生，泰德和罗宾刚刚开始做，这是一种联系，谁发明的真的很重要吗？
It doesn't matter that I invented it.
是我发明的并不重要。
Go on.
继续。
Good.
好的。
And this old man.
还有这个老人。
He must'd meet me.
他一定会见我的。
Fell in love with you.
爱上你了。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
in reverse.
相反。
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
And if commercials, back to Shell.
如果是广告，回到壳牌。
Craig, not to bring up old wounds or get a viewer, mail, whatever, but I want to talk about the finale for one second without any spoilers, which is the script for the finale was too fat for the amount of time we had.
克雷格，不是为了提起旧伤或吸引观众，邮件，等等，但我想在没有任何剧透的情况下谈论一下结局，因为结局的剧本对于我们的时间来说太胖了。
Even though it was a two-part episode, ads were very expensive.
尽管它是两集，但广告非常昂贵。
A lot of people were gonna be tuning in.
很多人都会收听。
You guys had to trim the episode, right?
你们必须剪辑这一集，对吧？
We did, yeah.
我们做到了，是的。
One of my top 10 life regrets is not fighting for like an extra half hour of that, but we'll get there.
我一生中十大遗憾之一就是没有争取额外的半个小时，但我们会到达那里。
You guys lost a scene with me and Kobe in the family.
你们在家里失去了我和科比的一场戏。
We did.
我们做到了。
That I think is on DVD extras if you...
我认为 DVD 的附加内容里有，如果你...
Oh, it is.
哦，是的。
People can go find it.
人们可以去寻找它。
Even on YouTube, I think, right?
我想即使在 YouTube 上也是如此，对吧？
Yeah, you can YouTube it.
是的，你可以通过 YouTube 观看。
It's like Ted, Robin, Finale, Cutscene.
就像泰德、罗宾、结局、过场动画。
It's a great scene, I in retrospect, I really wish it was in there.
这是一个很棒的场景，我现在回想起来，我真的希望它在那里。
And it ends with a major joke, right?
最后以一个大笑话结束，对吧？
Like isn't it?
就像不是吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
I forget what the exacts.
具体是什么我忘记了。
Oh man, it would have we should, yeah.
噢，伙计，我们应该这样做，是的。
But I remember the finale, which obviously is tear-filled and beautiful, or had so many moments that were so moving, especially like around the table, but I remember when I read it, I think that was the moment that got me because it was such a signifier of their history and their fondness for each other, and their shorthand and...
但我记得结局，显然是充满泪水和美丽的，或者有很多如此感人的时刻，尤其是在桌子周围，但我记得当我读到它时，我认为那是让我感动的时刻，因为它是他们的历史和他们对彼此的喜爱的象征，以及他们的速记和......
Yeah, it's their connection.
是的，这是他们的联系。
I think he leaves after she says something, and then he just turns out the door and gives her a salute.
我想她说了些什么之后他就离开了，然后他就走出门并向她行了个礼。
Like, you know, even going to watch those, even saying it, you know.
就像，你知道，甚至去看那些，甚至说出来，你知道。
But it's gonna bother me, that it's not in there.
但它不在那里，这会让我烦恼。
Anyway, we'll get there.
无论如何，我们会到达那里。
Hey, I have a question for you, since you're so, since you and Carter were so rom-com literate, When they come to the Thanksgiving, and Ted is talking to the guys in one room, and Robin's talking to Lily in the kitchen, and they're both telling about their night, and with all the flashbacks, it very much reminded me of Bruno Kirby and Carrie Fisher calling- On the phone and the t-shirt screen as it's like the four, yeah, it's great, right?
嘿，我有一个问题要问你，既然你是这样，因为你和卡特对浪漫喜剧很有了解，当他们来到感恩节时，泰德正在一个房间里与其他人交谈，罗宾正在厨房里与莉莉交谈，他们都在讲述他们的夜晚，所有的闪回，这让我想起了布鲁诺·柯比和凯莉·费舍尔的电话——在电话和 T 恤屏幕上，因为它就像四个，是的，太棒了，对吧？
Do you think that was conscious or unconscious?
你认为这是有意识的还是无意识的？
I think it was conscious.
我认为这是有意识的。
We love when Harry Metzali so much.
我们非常喜欢哈利·梅扎利。
We did many a nod, some might call it rip-offs, but it's literally, they slept together.
我们做了很多点头，有些人可能称之为剽窃，但实际上，他们睡在一起了。
It's the same beat as Bruno Kirby calling, you know, Billy Crystal called Bruno Kirby.
这和布鲁诺·柯比打电话的节奏是一样的，你知道，比利·克里斯托打电话给布鲁诺·柯比。
It's a, yeah, I think that's, you know, that's like the bible that, when Harry Met Sally is like, it's just gonna get referenced.
这是，是的，我认为这就像圣经一样，当哈利遇见莎莉时，它就会被引用。
It's just such an all-timer.
它就是这样一个历史悠久的人。
But yeah, I mean, that's the other thing.
但是，是的，我的意思是，那是另一回事。
I love that this episode had the flashbacks, it had the mystery, wait, what crazy thing happened last night?
我喜欢这一集的闪回，它有神秘感，等等，昨晚发生了什么疯狂的事情？
played with time.
与时间玩耍。
It had the inside jokes.
它有内部笑话。
It had the incredibly silly sort of B story and the very emotional A story.
它有极其愚蠢的 B 故事和非常感人的 A 故事。
It's hard to do that every week.
每周都这样做很难。
It's hard to do that 24 episodes a year and to have all of those things firing.
一年拍 24 集并且让所有这些东西都火起来是很困难的。
But goddamn, this one does.
但该死的，这个确实如此。
This one has it has them all firing and it really is joyful.
这一次让他们都兴奋起来，这真的很令人高兴。
this one.
这个。
Um, I'm trying to remember when, when did the Borat movie come out?
嗯，我在努力回忆波拉特电影什么时候上映的？
Because there's a poor edge with the wrong, the wrong, how many days in a month, but it was funny because like Borat at that point was like oversaturated and a little bit done.
因为有一个糟糕的边缘，错误，错误，一个月中有多少天，但这很有趣，因为就像波拉特那样，在这一点上就像过度饱和并且有点完成了。
Yes, but there's something about it now that is like even funnier than when it was.
是的，但现在比以前更有趣了。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes, that joke aged well.
是的，这个笑话很古老。
It did age well by age weirdly well.
它确实随着年龄的增长而奇怪地很好。
Yeah.
是的。
Because Borat just became like a thing in the culture rather than like a movie event, it's marked by time.
因为波拉特只是变得像文化中的一件事情，而不是像电影事件，所以它被时间标记了。
Yes.
是的。
So it was that was great.
所以这真是太棒了。
Speaking of another nod to television, I would say, and maybe because I saw it in college after a lot of sandwiches, but my sophomore year of college, we used to watch The Simpsons a lot as college folks did in those days.
说到对电视的另一种认可，我会说，也许是因为我在大学里吃了很多三明治后才看到它，但在大学二年级时，我们经常像那时的大学生一样看《辛普森一家》。
All sandwich stuff.
所有三明治的东西。
And it's the Side Show Bob Cape Fear episode, which I still think is one of the greatest episodes of television.
这是《杂耍鲍勃·开普菲尔》一集，我仍然认为这是电视上最伟大的剧集之一。
Amazing episode.
精彩的一集。
Amazing.
惊人的。
So the way that Side Show Bob taunts Bart and telegraphs, I'm going to kill you.
所以，就像余兴节目鲍勃嘲笑巴特和电报的方式一样，我要杀了你。
Yeah.
是的。
Is just what Marshall does to Barney with a slap.
这就是马歇尔对巴尼打的一巴掌。
Like, so good in this, he's so good at doing that.
就像，他在这方面很擅长，他在这方面也很擅长。
He's doing, like, Sideshow Bob, about the slap rather than murder, but it really reminded me of that episode.
他正在做的，就像杂耍鲍勃一样，关于耳光而不是谋杀，但这确实让我想起了那一集。
It is Sideshow Bob.
这是杂耍鲍勃。
See what I got going on here with the turkeys, their hands, but they're also turkeys.
看看我在这里对火鸡和它们的手做了什么，但它们也是火鸡。
He played that with such, like, absolute, like, ominous glee.
他带着这样的、绝对的、不祥的欢乐来演奏这首曲子。
He leaned into that speed so hard.
他如此努力地追求那个速度。
He's great.
他很棒。
Everyone was good in this.
每个人都在这方面做得很好。
Everyone was good.
每个人都很好。
trying to keep the group from devolving an anarchy and have this one nice Thanksgiving and then giving up and getting drunk and going, I don't care, get up and get out of here, this sucks.
试图阻止团队陷入无政府状态，过一个愉快的感恩节，然后放弃，喝醉了然后走，我不在乎，站起来离开这里，这很糟糕。
Like everybody had somewhere to go and then Bob was just kind of writing on his own for a chill plan.
就像每个人都有地方可去一样，然后鲍勃只是自己写一个冷静的计划。
But in some ways, Bob, not just because of the many, many hilarious old-person jokes, which I wanna get into, but it's almost like having Bob there forced, So like, when an outsider is present, it highlights the insider-ness.
但在某些方面，鲍勃，不仅仅是因为有很多很多搞笑的老人笑话，我想了解这些，但这几乎就像让鲍勃被迫在那里一样，所以就像，当一个局外人在场时，它凸显了内部人性。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah, I think that is a key to this episode.
是的，我认为这是这一集的关键。
I don't think the episode works without Bob.
我认为如果没有鲍勃，这一集就不会成功。
Yeah, you absolutely need Bob.
是的，你绝对需要鲍勃。
And also what a pleasant slash innocuous presence he is.
而且他是一个多么令人愉快的无害的存在。
Like even during the end song, he's just leaning against the wall.
就像在片尾曲中一样，他只是靠在墙上。
He's just chilling.
他只是感到寒冷。
Having a great time.
玩得很开心。
Like he actually seems like a good dude.
就好像他实际上看起来是一个好人。
Yeah, he does.
是的，他确实如此。
He seems like a good dude.
他看起来是个好人。
Ted's frying the heat of him.
特德正在激怒他。
seems very chill.
看起来很冷淡。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's song.
这就是歌。
And I will give Carter base.
我会给卡特基地。
That is a Carter base original.
那是卡特基地原件。
I maybe contributed a couple of little touches here and there, but sometimes like one or the other of us took a song a little more than the other.
我可能会在这里或那里做出一些小改动，但有时就像我们中的一个人比另一个人多听一首歌。
I just want to give credit where it's due.
我只是想给予应得的信任。
You just got slapped is an anthem by Carter is just a frickin banger all time and also if you want to get sports arenas like when another team is losing.
《你刚刚被打了一巴掌》是卡特的一首赞歌，一直以来都是一个令人讨厌的家伙，如果你想像另一支球队输球时那样进入体育场。
I really do.
我真的这么做。
Do people play it?
人们玩它吗？
Yeah.
是的。
If anyone knows where those clips are, I know it has happened.
如果有人知道这些片段在哪里，我就知道这件事已经发生了。
I think there was a team that did it a lot, like a hockey team maybe.
我认为有一支球队做了很多这样的事情，比如曲棍球队。
That song is transcendently good and the great Carter Bay deserves most of the credit on that one.
那首歌非常好，伟大的卡特贝值得这首歌的大部分功劳。
If you want Jason Siegel to be very interested.
如果你想让杰森·西格尔非常感兴趣。
See what giving credit is like Alex?
看看亚历克斯的信用是什么？
See what I just gave credit to Carter.
看看我刚才对卡特的评价。
I don't need to fight about it.
我不需要为此争吵。
See what that feels like it felt good.
看看是什么感觉，感觉很好。
And it's just and so that's what we should tell Joel.
这就是我们应该告诉乔尔的。
All right, if you want to get Jason Siegel very interested in how I met your mother episode, give him slaps.
好吧，如果你想让杰森·西格尔对《我是如何遇见你母亲》一集非常感兴趣，就给他耳光吧。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
And give him a frickin all time at now.
现在就一直骂他吧。
He was he was all in.
他就是他全力以赴的。
He was locked and loaded.
他已上锁并上膛。
He knew this was a good one.
他知道这是一件好事。
He knows this is a good one.
This is just that episode that's good for everybody, including Bob.
这只是对每个人都有好处的一集，包括鲍勃。
It's just like everybody plus Bob has like A-game material in this episode and for me I remember really liking this episode as an actor because I got to do what I felt like I was really hired for Which is the more sincere stuff.
就像每个人加上鲍勃在这一集里都喜欢A-game材料一样，对我来说，我记得作为演员真的很喜欢这一集，因为我必须做我觉得我真正被雇用的事情，这是更真诚的事情。
That's as the romantic protagonist, but then We're deep enough into the weeds of the show that you guys had a lot of like go-to Ted humor Yeah, and especially Ted Robin dynamic humor, which which we had really found by that point So I felt like both funny and I got to be like a really good actor, you know, it was just like everyone you're right Everyone was in their sweet spot and Ted Ted also got to be a little bit of a dick, right?
那是浪漫的主角，但是我们对这部剧的了解足够深入，你们有很多喜欢的泰德幽默是的，尤其是泰德罗宾的动态幽默，我们在那一点上真的发现了所以我觉得既有趣又我必须成为一个非常好的演员，你知道，就像每个人一样，你是对的每个人都处于他们的最佳状态，泰德泰德也必须是一个混蛋，对吧？
He was a little sharp towards Bob Bob did bother Ted.
他对鲍勃有点尖锐，鲍勃确实让特德烦恼。
He pretended it didn't but it did and Those scenes with Robin in the kitchen and cooking together were really awkward and painful in a great way.
他假装没有，但事实确实如此，那些和罗宾在厨房里一起做饭的场景在很大程度上真的很尴尬和痛苦。
Yeah Well, that's the other thing you guys did was you never Sanctified anyone like no one was ever everyone had spiky, sharp edges.
是的，好吧，这就是你们所做的另一件事，就是你们从来没有圣化过任何人，就像没有人曾经每个人都有尖锐的锋利边缘一样。
And I think that's what makes you trust you guys as storytellers and the characters as people you wanna spend time with because they have the recognizable whiff of reality about them, you know?
我认为这就是为什么你会相信你们是讲故事的人，相信这些角色是你想与之共度时光的人，因为他们身上有明显的现实气息，你知道吗？
Yes, this episode is one of those work.
是的，这一集就是其中的一部作品。
Every now and again, there's an episode that's 22 minutes or like what you said about the finale.
时不时地，会有一集长达 22 分钟或者就像你所说的结局一样。
I always wish there was more time in every fucking episode we ever did.
我总是希望我们拍的每一集他妈的都有更多的时间。
But every once in a while, I go, this did all the things in 21 and a half minutes.
但每隔一段时间，我就会去，这在 21 分半钟内完成了所有事情。
this kind of did all the things.
这样就完成了所有的事情。
I don't think we left anything on the playing field here.
我认为我们没有在比赛场上留下任何东西。
This one just somehow fit into like 22 minutes.
不知怎么的，这个时间大约是 22 分钟。
It's not even quite, I think.
我想，这还不完全是。
And it did all the things.
它完成了所有的事情。
And that's really hard to do.
而这真的很难做到。
It doesn't happen every time.
并不是每次都会发生。
And I just, I really appreciate this one.
我只是，我真的很欣赏这个。
Yeah, it must have been fun.
是的，一定很有趣。
Again, I always like those moments where I can picture the writer's room going, okay, 20 old jokes go.
再说一次，我总是喜欢那些我可以想象编剧房间里的情景的时刻，好吧，20 个老笑话都过去了。
Right.
正确的。
What's a funny way?
有什么好笑的方法呢？
but it's a really twisted, ornate, overly long way to say someone's old.
但这是一种非常扭曲、华丽、过于冗长的说法来说某人老了。
Yeah.
是的。
I love Robin is dating Orville Rhett and Bocker.
我爱罗宾正在与奥维尔·瑞德和博克约会。
This is great.
这太棒了。
I loved 41 because I just like this because he's a thousand years old.
我爱41，因为我喜欢这个，因为他已经一千年了。
I like that's not even a joke.
我喜欢这甚至不是一个笑话。
Just not even joke.
简直连开玩笑都没有。
It's just like the joke is it's just a joke.
就像笑话一样，这只是一个笑话。
It's just to be him being a baby.
这只是让他成为一个婴儿。
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
I liked Noah gave him shotgun in the arc shotgun in the arc.
我喜欢诺亚给他的弧线霰弹枪。
Yeah.
是的。
I love what there's just a little tight five by 10 there on old jokes.
我喜欢老笑话中五乘十的关系。
He's about to go into some Yomama jokes after that.
之后他就要讲一些 Yomama 的笑话了。
Exactly, exactly.
完全正确。
But I also really liked, I remember liking Kobe and I being awkward together and the humor, like just, we weren't playing jokes as much as like behavior, you know?
但我也真的很喜欢，我记得喜欢科比和我在一起的尴尬和幽默，就像我们不是在开玩笑，而是像行为一样，你知道吗？
Yeah, and what I like about that is it's the thing that did make the show different from the other shows on CBS and most other sitcoms.
是的，我喜欢这一点，因为它确实使该节目与哥伦比亚广播公司的其他节目和大多数其他情景喜剧不同。
The show has a memory.
这部剧有记忆。
It doesn't reset week to week.
它不会每周重置。
It doesn't shake up the address sketch.
它不会动摇地址草图。
The memory is, if two people are very serious together, like Ted and Robin were, and they break up, it takes a long time for it to normalize.
记忆是，如果两个人在一起非常认真，就像泰德和罗宾那样，然后他们分手了，需要很长时间才能恢复正常。
And sometimes it doesn't.
有时却并非如此。
Sometimes they have to stop being friends.
有时他们不得不停止做朋友。
And the idea that it's not just like, and they're back to normal.
而且这个想法不仅仅是像，而且他们又恢复了正常。
Yes.
是的。
It's like things happen and they matter.
就好像事情发生了并且它们很重要。
There were consequences to things happening.
发生的事情是有后果的。
There is a accumulation of emotional, you know, repercussions that matters and stays and doesn't keep disappearing into nothingness just because it's comedically convenient for it to disappear.
你知道，情感的积累是重要的，并且会持续存在，并且不会仅仅因为它的消失在喜剧上很方便而不断消失在虚无中。
Life doesn't work that way, and often sitcoms do work that way, but not this one, and I'm proud of that.
生活不是这样的，情景喜剧经常也是这样，但这个不是，我为此感到自豪。
Yeah, you guys were trying to inject what you loved about long-form narrative and movies and books into a sitcom.
是的，你们试图将你们喜欢的长篇叙事、电影和书籍注入情景喜剧中。
You were taking a kind of tried-and-true form and trying to update it, in certain ways.
你采用了一种经过验证的形式，并试图以某些方式更新它。
What happened last week happened last week?
上周发生了什么上周发生了什么？
Happened last week, exactly, exactly.
发生在上周，完全，完全。
Um, I love when Robin said I'd already broken the ice with my cool pie fact.
嗯，我喜欢罗宾说我已经用我很酷的馅饼事实打破了僵局。
It almost feels like before Robin dated Ted.
感觉就像罗宾和泰德约会之前一样。
Did she have cool pie facts?
她有很酷的馅饼事实吗？
Was that where we're Ted's fun facts?
这就是特德的有趣事实吗？
Like I mean, look, there are connections between these two.
就像我的意思是，看，这两者之间存在联系。
It lines up.
它排队。
Ted would do a cool pie fact.
特德会做一个很酷的馅饼事实。
I liked Cripkeeper's dad.
我喜欢 Cripkeeper 的爸爸。
I had already mentioned that.
我已经提到过这一点。
I love Kobe's run when I don't remember all of them, but which she said, that is a truth fact.
当我不记得所有的事情时，我喜欢科比的跑步，但她说，这是事实。
Yes, that is a truth fact.
是的，这是事实。
That was a Greg Malinsism in the room.
这就是房间里的格雷格·马林主义。
That is a truth fact.
这是事实。
I think he was stealing that from somebody.
我认为他是从某人那里偷来的。
He like heard that in real life somewhere and said, we're going to say, but when Kobe says you are correct, sir, she's doing the Ed McMahon.
他就像在现实生活中的某个地方听到的那样，然后说，我们要说，但是当科比说你是对的，先生，她正在模仿埃德·麦克马洪。
She's doing a Carcenio sketch, Ed McMahon, and we're just putting it.
艾德·麦克马洪，她正在画卡西尼奥的草图，我们只是把它放上去。
That's just a bunch of comedy writers loving, you know, Dana Carvey doing Johnny Carson and just throwing that in the middle of Robins, seeing the bully in the kitchen.
那只是一群喜剧作家喜欢，你知道，达纳·卡维扮演约翰尼·卡森，然后把它扔到罗宾斯中间，看到厨房里的恶霸。
Barney's meltdown is incredible.
巴尼的崩溃令人难以置信。
Like, I've lost 10 pounds, my suits are wearing me.
就像，我减掉了 10 磅，我的西装在穿我。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
You're allowed to slap my face, sir, but you're not allowed to slap my mind.
先生，你可以打我的脸，但不可以打我的心。
I said good day, sir.
我说了声再见，先生。
I say good day.
我说美好的一天。
Did he add, I said good day, sir, or was that in there?
他有没有补充说，我说了再见，先生，或者那句话就在里面吗？
No, I think we had a thing for that.
不，我认为我们对此有兴趣。
We were, that was a shiny toy in the writer's room, I think.
我想，我们是作家房间里的一个闪亮的玩具。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, and just ending on friendship as an involuntary reflex, I, again, I just, I was always honored to be on a show that would say stuff like that.
是的，最后以友谊作为一种不自觉的反射，我，再说一次，我只是，我总是很荣幸能参加一个会说这样的话的节目。
That's cool.
这很酷。
My memory of breaking that episode, like I think I was, that was a me week, I think that episode, but Carter went off and wrote the song, you know, it was just the perfect division of labor.
我对打破那一集的记忆，就像我想的那样，那是我的一周，我认为那一集，但卡特去写了这首歌，你知道，这只是完美的分工。
It was like, I was sort of doing that episode with Matt Coon in the writer's room.
就好像，我正在编剧的房间里和马特·库恩一起做那一集。
Carter was doing this amazing song and just making sure that was amazing and doing that That was seagull.
卡特正在创作这首令人惊叹的歌曲，并确保这首歌令人惊叹，并且做到了那是海鸥。
It was just like everyone was doing their thing.
就像每个人都在做自己的事情一样。
And I remember reverse engineering the story from that, my favorite.
我记得对这个故事进行逆向工程，这是我最喜欢的。
The thing I wanted the story to be about is that line, Josh.
我想要这个故事讲述的就是那句话，乔什。
I wanted it to be involuntary friendship and like, how do we get there?
我希望这是一种非自愿的友谊，我们怎样才能到达那里？
And for the thing, I will give Alec Angel credit.
对于这件事，我要归功于亚历克·安吉尔。
The thing that really sparked it was made for General Colonel.
真正引发它的东西是为上校设计的。
It was all that stuff.
就是这些东西。
That was it.
就是这样。
And I said, if we can use that, and that's what's gonna be the through line of the whole episode.
我说，如果我们可以使用它，那就是整集的主线。
And I'm very proud of how I came out.
我对自己的表现感到非常自豪。
Writers listening, which I know a lot of writers listen to the show, because we talk about process a lot.
作家在听，我知道很多作家在听节目，因为我们谈论了很多过程。
Starting, like getting the ending that is like incredible and working towards it is a good writer trick.
开始，就像得到令人难以置信的结局一样，并努力实现它是一个很好的作家技巧。
You know?
你知道？
Sometimes your story will demand it be something by else by the end.
有时你的故事最终会要求它是别的东西。
But we started, even if you end up going somewhere else with it, but often you end in that spot.
但我们开始了，即使你最终会带着它去别的地方，但通常你会在那个地方结束。
If you know that's good and you know that is where you will stick your landing, that's where you're sailing towards, it's so great.
如果你知道那很好，你知道那是你着陆的地方，那是你航行的方向，那就太好了。
And you also know that that's where you want the chess piece to move to set up the next story.
而且您还知道这就是您希望棋子移动的位置以设置下一个故事。
Yes, that's my favorite way to break a story is to know what that core thought is, what you're really saying, what it really has to get to.
是的，这是我最喜欢的讲述故事的方式，就是知道核心思想是什么，你真正在说什么，它真正要表达什么。
And then it's fun reverse engineering to get to that moment.
然后通过逆向工程到达那一刻是很有趣的。
It's almost like you could almost write the narrator Ted's final thought and then we're back.
就好像你几乎可以写出叙述者特德的最终想法，然后我们就回来了。
Yeah, and how great is Saget to Bob Saget, another great Bob, two great Bobs in this episode.
是的，Saget 对 Bob Saget 来说是多么伟大，另一个伟大的鲍勃，本集中的两个伟大的鲍勃。
Bob Saget doing that narration is very moving.
鲍勃·萨吉特的旁白非常感人。
We've also lost him since the show, and I'm just finding re-watching this, Josh, that Saggot was just such a secret weapon of the show.
自从这部剧之后，我们也失去了他，乔什，我只是在重看这个节目，发现萨格特就是这部剧的秘密武器。
His narrations are so lovely and heartfelt, and there's humor and wisdom.
他的叙述是如此可爱和真挚，而且充满幽默和智慧。
The sound or the timbre of a voice is so important, especially when it's only the voice.
声音或声音的音色非常重要，尤其是当它只是声音时。
And there's something, you know, the show starts and it's just like stock footage of New York, and you hear Bob snark on something.
你知道，有一些东西，节目开始了，就像纽约的素材库一样，你听到鲍勃对什么东西咆哮。
You just feel like you're in good hands.
你只是感觉自己得到了很好的照顾。
You're in good hands.
你得到了很好的照顾。
You feel very good hands.
你感觉手很好。
Yeah, it's a great time.
是的，这是一个美好的时光。
Shout out to us.
向我们大声喊叫。
I also, I'm just really enjoying watching this show again.
我也，我真的很喜欢再次观看这个节目。
I hope that people are re-watching it with us or just enjoying this walk down memory lane.
我希望人们能和我们一起重新观看它，或者只是享受这段记忆之路。
I did want to say one other thing to just close out this segment.
我确实想说另一件事来结束这个部分。
We started off with a disagreement, if it was Alec or Joel who came up with this joke.
我们一开始就存在分歧，认为这个笑话是亚历克还是乔尔想出来的。
I thought, you know, there's a thing in this episode which is, no, you did that.
我想，你知道，这一集中有一件事是，不，你做到了。
No, you did that.
不，你就是这么做的。
who kissed to.
谁亲吻了。
Yeah.
是的。
And when I watched it, I was like, I thought Kobe and I did that as well as you could have, because you cannot tell who starts.
当我观看比赛时，我想，我认为科比和我做到了你们能做到的那么好，因为你无法分辨谁先发。
You cannot tell.
你说不出来。
Yeah.
是的。
It's actually very rock and roll.
它实际上非常摇滚。
Very organic.
非常有机。
It's very organic.
这是非常有机的。
Very good.
非常好。
You guys are so good together in this one.
你们在这一部里配合得很好。
And you guys are always good together.
而且你们总是在一起很好。
But you have to play like 75 different emotional beats in 21 minutes while there's fucking slaps and old guys and songs happening and it doesn't feel like your guy's emotional story is short-shrifted in any way.
但你必须在 21 分钟内演奏 75 个不同的情感节拍，同时还有他妈的耳光、老家伙和歌曲发生，而且你不会觉得你的家伙的情感故事在任何方面都是草率的。
Nor does it feel like we have to cut through the noise by amping it up.
我们也不觉得必须通过放大噪音来消除噪音。
It felt like we really trusted.
感觉我们真的很信任。
I really love the scene in Ted's bedroom between the two of them.
我真的很喜欢他们两人在特德卧室里的场景。
Me too.
我也是。
It's heartbreaking.
真是令人心碎。
It's really angry.
实在是太生气了。
It's really angry and they're really ending it.
这真的很生气，他们真的要结束它了。
I was on the edge of my seat.
我坐在座位边上。
Like no one's at their best, but they're kind of at their best.
就像没有人处于最佳状态一样，但他们却处于最佳状态。
Like it's weird.
好像很奇怪一样。
Yeah.
是的。
So it's a good one.
所以这是一件好事。
Well, this was a great episode.
嗯，这是一个很棒的插曲。
I really enjoyed talking about it.
我真的很喜欢谈论它。
We're going to talk I want you to get in a room with Joel and just work this out and you're going to come back to us we're gonna Yeah, I don't know what's gonna happen.
我们要谈谈，我希望你和乔尔一起进入一个房间，解决这个问题，然后你就会回到我们身边，我们会的，是的，我不知道会发生什么。
You're gonna find a way to work this out I just want to have one nice lapsgiving with you guys.
你会找到一种方法来解决这个问题的，我只是想和你们一起度过愉快的时光。
There's a kernel of truth in each of your stories Have reached the part of the show we call the sea blog Who came up with this joke but Joel, this was all Joel.
你的每个故事都有一个真理的核心已经到达我们称之为海洋博客的节目部分谁想出了这个笑话但乔尔，这都是乔尔。
This is Joel's, yeah, this is Joel's.
这是乔尔的，是的，这是乔尔的。
We've had a great time talking about Slap's Giving, episode nine of season three.
我们很高兴地谈论了第三季第九集《Slap's Giving》。
We're having a great time every week on this show.
我们每周都在这个节目中度过愉快的时光。
If you are enjoying this podcast, please subscribe, tell your friends.
如果您喜欢这个播客，请订阅，告诉您的朋友。
We would love more how I met your mother fans to be listening.
我们更希望我能见到你妈妈的粉丝来倾听。
There are more how I met your mother fans out there than our listeners of this show.
我与你母亲的粉丝见面的方式比我们这个节目的听众还多。
We can assure you of that.
我们可以向你保证。
But if all of the How I Met Your Mother fans in the world listen to the show, we would be Joe Rogan.
但如果世界上所有《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝都听这个节目，我们就是乔·罗根。
I mean, we'd be more popular than we'd be like.
我的意思是，我们会比我们想象的更受欢迎。
We'd be the most popular podcast in the world.
我们将成为世界上最受欢迎的播客。
So we'd like to get, we'd like to approach those heights.
所以我们希望达到这些高度。
So please let your friends know.
所以请让你的朋友知道。
Also, if you're loving this show, as you know, we often play an audio clip at the beginning from a fan of the podcast or the show.
另外，如果您喜欢这个节目，如您所知，我们经常在开头播放播客或节目粉丝的音频剪辑。
We read letters in this last section.
我们在最后一节中阅读了信件。
So please go to how we made your mother.com, H-W-M-Y-M, go up to contact Alec, built this website on Squarespace and follow the directions, they're quite simple.
所以请去看看我们如何制作你的 mother.com，H-W-M-Y-M，联系 Alec，在 Squarespace 上建立这个网站并按照说明进行操作，它们非常简单。
But let us know how the podcast is landing on you, what how we met your mother means to you, we'd love to hear from you.
但请让我们知道播客是如何登陆您的，我们如何认识您母亲对您意味着什么，我们很乐意听取您的意见。
And today we have a great letter that Craig is gonna read.
今天我们有一封很棒的信，克雷格要读。
Yes, and I wanna add, if you're DM'ing me or Josh a cool story or a cool message, please also send that cool story or message to Alec and to what weird Josh just said, because if it comes to Josh and my DMs, we might not get to it.
是的，我想补充一点，如果您向我或乔什发送了一个很酷的故事或消息，请同时将这个很酷的故事或消息发送给亚历克以及乔什刚才所说的奇怪的话，因为如果涉及到乔什和我的私信，我们可能无法处理。
And I sometimes discover them way after the fact, and so please send the messages to the podcast.
有时我会在事后才发现它们，所以请将消息发送到播客。
And by the way, also, if you worked on the show, and you're listening, we know a lot of people that worked at the show were listening, we'd love, love, love to hear your stories, and please send them in as well, you can contact any of us however you want to, or just to go on there and please tell us about your time.
顺便说一句，如果你在节目中工作，并且你在听，我们知道很多在节目中工作的人都在听，我们非常非常喜欢听你的故事，也请把它们发给我们，你可以随心所欲地联系我们中的任何一个人，或者只是继续在那里，请告诉我们你的时间。
And if you're a friend of Alex, I'm on a steel credit for something He came up with, please also send those in.
如果你是亚历克斯的朋友，我因为他想出的一些东西而获得了钢铁信用，也请把它们寄过来。
Here we go.
开始了。
From Harrison in Alabama.
来自阿拉巴马州的哈里森。
Hemium, I love this letter has a title.
Hemium，我喜欢这封信有一个标题。
Hemium, a reflection through the years.
Hemium，多年来的反思。
Respect Harrison for putting a title.
尊重哈里森授予的头衔。
I've watched how I met your mother several times now, starting in my late 20s.
从我二十多岁开始，我已经看过好几次我是如何遇见你母亲的了。
Each rewatch has felt like a time capsule, bringing back memories of where I was in life and how the show resonated with me differently each time.
每次重看都感觉就像一个时间胶囊，带回我生活中的记忆，以及每次这部剧如何与我产生不同的共鸣。
The first time I watched it, I was in the thick of my single phase.
我第一次看它时，正处于我的单相阶段。
Barney, for better or worse, became a kind of misguided inspiration.
无论好坏，巴尼都成为了一种被误导的灵感。
His boldness gave me the push I needed to step out of my shy, late bloomer shell.
他的大胆给了我所需的推动力，让我走出害羞、大器晚成的外壳。
Whether it was at bars, airports, gyms, or even once at a marathon, I felt his spirit urging me to take chances and not fear rejection.
无论是在酒吧、机场、健身房，甚至是在马拉松比赛中，我都能感受到他的精神在敦促我抓住机会，不要害怕被拒绝。
Looking back, I did plenty of things I wouldn't repeat, but I don't regret them.
回想起来，我做了很多事情，我不会重复，但我不后悔。
That era shaped me into who I am today.
那个时代塑造了今天的我。
Years later, in my mid 30s, I re-watched the show and found myself connecting with Ted.
多年后，在我 30 多岁的时候，我重新观看了这部剧，发现自己与特德产生了共鸣。
I was ready for something deeper, but couldn't seem to find the one.
我已经准备好做更深入的事情了，但似乎找不到那个。
I even revisited past relationships, wondering if maybe it had just been bad timing the first time around, but I learned that love doesn't operate on a schedule.
我什至重新审视过去的关系，想知道是否第一次的时机不好，但我了解到爱情不会按计划进行。
It shows up when it's meant to, not when we expect it.
它会在该出现的时候出现，而不是在我们期望的时候出现。
Now, as I near 40, and watch the series again, this time with my wife, I find myself drawn to Marshall and Lully.
现在，当我快 40 岁的时候，再次观看这部连续剧，这次是和我的妻子一起，我发现自己被《马歇尔和露利》所吸引。
Their partnership isn't perfect, but it's full of grace, forgiveness, and unwavering support.
他们的伙伴关系并不完美，但充满了恩典、宽恕和坚定不移的支持。
Watching them reminds me of what I strive to bring to my own marriage, kindness, humor, and the courage to weather life's ups and downs together.
看着他们让我想起了我努力为自己的婚姻带来的东西：善良、幽默，以及共同度过生活风风雨雨的勇气。
Who knows?
谁知道？
Maybe the next time I watch it, I'll be a parent.
也许下次我看到它时，我就会成为父母。
And I'll find a new meaning in the show once again.
我会再次在这个节目中找到新的意义。
I could go on about how much this series and the podcast means to me.
我可以继续讲述这个系列和播客对我的意义。
Thank you for creating something so heartfelt, hilarious, and real.
感谢您创造了如此真诚、搞笑和真实的东西。
It's more than a show.
这不仅仅是一场表演。
It's a companion through life stages.
它是人生各个阶段的陪伴。
And for that, I'm endlessly grateful.
为此，我无限感激。
That was great, Harrison.
太棒了，哈里森。
Thank you.
谢谢。
You know, it really speaks to something we say on the show that, you know, art, if it's good art, and I think we made some good art here, it changes as you change, you know, you enter it at different.
你知道，这确实符合我们在节目中所说的，你知道，艺术，如果它是好的艺术，我认为我们在这里制作了一些好的艺术，它会随着你的改变而改变，你知道，你以不同的方式进入它。
He took us through it.
他带我们经历了这一切。
He took us through exactly that process.
他带领我们经历了这个过程。
I love that letter for that reason.
因此我喜欢这封信。
It reminded me of, you know, the evolutionary picture of, like, the ape turning into the human.
这让我想起了猿变成人类的进化图景。
But it feels like there's stages of, let's just say, a man's life, you know, where, you know, you're trying to.
但感觉就像一个人的一生有几个阶段，你知道，你知道，你正在努力。
You know, you're trying to get out.
你知道，你正试图逃脱。
I liked how he honored that the part of him that was like a Barney was trying to get over his shyness and his discomfort.
我喜欢他对自己像巴尼一样试图克服害羞和不适的部分的尊重。
Yeah, that was a nice mention of Barney.
是的，这是对巴尼的一个很好的提及。
I haven't quite heard it exactly like that.
我还没有听过完全一样的说法。
Barney made me get out of my shell to try to be a little bit absurd at times.
巴尼有时让我走出自己的外壳，尝试变得有点荒唐。
And I needed that cartoonishness for two seconds to right bloom or something.
我需要那种卡通性两秒钟才能正确绽放或其他东西。
There's something nice about that.
这有一些好处。
Yeah, it's like the virtuous side of Barney.
是的，这就像巴尼善良的一面。
And then as he got older, he said, Oh, I'm actually more interested in like connection intimacy.
然后随着年龄的增长，他说，哦，我实际上对亲密关系更感兴趣。
And I would love to meet someone.
我很想认识一个人。
And I like how there was just the thing now alongside my wife, like just dropping that in like, oh, I got married.
我喜欢现在在我妻子身边的事情，就像把它扔进去一样，哦，我结婚了。
And then Marshall Lilly, like, if you're completely far from marriage, children, you know, cohabitation, Marshall Lilly are not going to land on you as much.
然后马歇尔·莉莉（Marshall Lilly），如果你完全远离婚姻、孩子、同居，马歇尔·莉莉（Marshall Lilly）就不会那么频繁地降临在你身上。
But once you get in that, like they're your peeps, you know, they're your people, like they're your North star.
但一旦你融入其中，就像他们是你的窥视者一样，你知道，他们是你的人民，就像他们是你的北极星一样。
They are your Now you're rooting for them.
他们是你的，现在你支持他们。
Yeah, I also just want to say we, I've talked a lot about attachment theory just because it fascinates me, but like, you really can mark again the evolution of Barney as an avoidant personality.
是的，我也只是想说，我们，我谈论了很多关于依恋理论，只是因为它让我着迷，但是，你真的可以再次将巴尼的演变标记为回避型人格。
Ted is an anxious, uh, a catcher and Marshall and Lily are securely attached.
特德是一个焦虑的，呃，一个捕手，马歇尔和莉莉是牢固的依恋。
So you really get this kind of, um, it's complete.
所以你真的得到了这样的，嗯，它完成了。
It's complete.
完成了。
It's a real art.
这是一门真正的艺术。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I love that letter.
嗯，我喜欢那封信。
That was great.
那很棒。
Thanks Harrison.
谢谢哈里森。
from you so keep them coming and keep them coming and listening and if you have any information about whether it was Alec Cordjol with the major general corporal colonel Joe.
请让他们过来听听，如果你有任何关于是否是亚历克·科乔尔和乔少将下士上校的信息。
Alec Aspenella please.
亚历克·阿斯佩内拉，请。
Right in.
就在。
We need to solve this.
我们需要解决这个问题。
Thanks for joining us and we'll see you next time.
感谢您加入我们，我们下次再见。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters are digital content producer Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves，他是 blue studio 的一员，我们的 Z 世代大师是数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg，副制作人 Katherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, And read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的，无论书在哪里》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substep.
你还可以在 Substep 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。